Catherine is with us in August Oh
Georgia
hey Catherine how are you hi B thank you
so much for taking my call
sure what's up well I am calling because
my husband and I we are working our debt
snowball we're working on cleaning up a
very big mess we have done a great job
of making um and we went to buy a car on
Friday the 13th got it back
got to go register it and found out it
was stolen and the money is gone the car
is gone and now we're looking at trying
to figure out whether it still makes
sense to go through and try and get rid
of my car which is the car we owe on and
get rid of that debt Tran so you bought
a car that had been stolen from an
individual yes we did and there are the
car thief was the seller unfortunately
yes
and how much money did you lose in this
transaction
we lost $1,800 oh yes that it's not
that'll shady at any point it didn't it
was we the biggest thing we had a
problem with if he didn't want to meet
it to police station because he said in
South Carolina you have to turn in your
plates and he didn't let me to take a
did right before he had to sell it I was
like we looked at the law it seemed to
check out more like okay we pulled up he
was really friendly everything she's
fine he had the title in hand he had the
key the title when title was a fake um
he had had it retitled that morning um
we don't I mean it was we when we went
to have it all done we dealt the police
and oh man and I thought you know it we
were obviously not and not at fault we
had a bill of sale we had gone and
checked the then and it had been cleared
we were there but when the police would
injected it was still one so we don't
they said it was pretty much you know
those don't work we didn't know so it's
just going to try to do our detail
a more that's a lot of work to scam 1800
bucks
yes we couldn't believe it he's working
his tail off for 2 grand I was a little
shocked we actually did end up getting
his name and address he called him back
up and he was high and just made it
right to us and he'll probably get
arrested but my money's still gone well
oh well I guess you can also file suit
on him for 1,800 bucks and well are you
driving my money yeah what a story
it's almost worth the 1,800 bucks for
the story if you weren't if it wasn't
[ __ ] if it wasn't such precious money
right now at your stage you know wow you
know I will say though when we went to
go register and after everything was
done we were invited to a church here we
hadn't gotten too plugged in with a
local church and it has been absolutely
incredible so heard all worked there so
it goes this is such a fear of going to
church here well my car got stolen that
has actually come up that's funny
I'm so sorry what a wild wild deal I
don't know if I've ever heard of
somebody going and getting a duplicate
title now I've heard of them doing
fraudulent transactions or no kind of
thing but that's that guy went to a lot
of trouble ok so now you've got a car
currently that you owe how much on we
owe 14,500 and you were trying to sell
it and get a cheap one
basically yeah we're still upside down
on it what we were going to do we were
going to come out we would come out with
about 1,500 dollars extra in bed but
it's better do 1,500 than the 14,000
yeah why are your household income we
are sitting at about fifteen one
thousand dollars how much other debt do
you have other than the 14 thousand
dollar car other than well here I'd have
to sit here and do that can I say the
amount you do get your calculator out
for an interest roof right now it's
eighty nine thousand five hundred minus
of fourteen thousand we're looking at
7500 okay
not even your house not counting a house
we've got a big ol mess yeah yeah you do
yeah and your income again was 6061 yeah
okay well the 14 if it went away it will
be
helpful towards 89 but it doesn't like
change your life on the 89 column
equality of the 89 you know we'd be
going yeah
drop the mic I'm out of here right but
it's 14 so you know so your idea maybe
is to just to keep it and pay it off
with the rest of the mess it's just
going to take you a few years right well
we were looking at that but we're also
where we're going to be looking at
changing his w-2 but we are getting
$4,500
or so back I haven't officially gotten
it back but also about $4,500 back from
taxes yeah but that will just go towards
your smallest debt what's your smallest
debt smallest that we just paid off more
than 5,700 so it being locked out with
the next one good good knock it out
that's what we do we just keep working
the debt snowball that doesn't change
the car equation much I'm probably going
to keep the car really high just because
it doesn't move the needle that much
okay it makes me sick every time I look
at it well if it makes you sick you may
want to sell it I don't want to keep
something it reminds me how stupid that
we've been selling if you want to sell
it if you want if you hate it you want
to sell it I'm only mad at your selling
it but if you wanted to keep it it again
it's not
I'm always looking at the ratios how
much can I change the whole situation
that's you know like if you if you sold
a car and you made and you paid off $500
well we wouldn't do that but if you sold
the car and you paid out $40,000 when we
do that we just said that a minute ago
you know so I'm trying to look at how
much does it move the needle in and how
fast you're out of that how fast you're
free so that you can then how fast you
can build wealth and so on and so that's
what I'm looking at but if it makes you
sick yeah so it that's fun
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
down
[Music]